monitamon Tandy the button Salonga
Williams in at hearted samaram our page
in Parliament start the first priority
today East and must be the refugee
crisis we are fighting against Islamic
state
why are we not ready to serve those who
are fleeing the Islamic state we have to
accept these people on European
territory
Jemison mentioned Hilton the unknown
thousand green see uncle often the
missing Hilfiger antion many people on
the edges of this chamber deliberately
seek to confuse economic migrants with
refugees many people are saying it's not
the same refugees on economic migrants
we know it but you can only solve it if
you have an illegal migration system a
blue card no 28 system as we have today
in Europe
LaVon does clone and concisely forbidden
clone is Jack Vale ahoy voyage
appositive Atari 7 a fini Martin
photo-essay was refilling serrano LaCava
the laboratory oh the polka company fr
no prophet ISA la voz rubella we
shouldn't ever dismiss a technology out
of hand
say God say father says offer or Tuesday
drop this receipt web tech respect a
darling European area my heart fills
with pride when I see citizens all
across Europe taking to the streets to
welcome refugees into their communities
plus stability children North Africa
fundamentally lots yoni his sufficiently
Libya to to discourse Azula Syria just
so no Nazi only known Nazi own he's on a
study don't start this right the
national offense and stop metric artists
held for the wounded - to collect occurs
the veil a home that 20 million a new
barriers in our Moodle
Lathan es el resultado de shoosh garre's
es el resultado de la guerra de da y
Afghanistan yeah verbum barriada Libya
EDA Burke elaborado confine a CAC own
yar momento a la guerra
in Syria